- There haven't been any full-blooded Filipino
that has been to the NBA, and I just wanna be the
first one, and I just wanna show everyone that we
can also make it.
My dad always told me to watch films
of Hakeem Olajuwon,
Tim Duncan, those guys, and I just kept
watching, you know, every day.
My dad was in the professional leagues in the
Philippines.
So, you know, he just taught me almost everything
he knows about the game.
And we always started with footwork.
You know, how to make easy shots.
- You know, you hear 7'0", and sometimes that
means 6'10", 6'11". He's legit 7'2"
So, it's just a breath of fresh air to work with
somebody whose goals are so in reach but also
knows and is willing to put the work in
that it's gonna
take to get there.
- Basketball is really a religion to the Philippines.
And, uh, every time you go out of your house, you'll
see a court here, court there.
You'll just see everyone playing basketball,
and that's just how we love the, the sport
in our country.
- He's definitely, like, a type of basketball player
that'll pass.
Like, he'll, he'll look for you.
He's not a selfish player.
- You know, the mentality in the States
when you're a
foreign player with hype and accolades coming in,
people wanna play against you.
You know, everybody has their goals,
and everybody's
trying to get on.
So what better way to get recruited to a college
than saying, "Hey, I had X amount of points and
rebounds and blocks against Kai Sotto
and here's my
film against him"?
I think he realizes that now, and he kinda brings
it to his opponents instead of waiting
for it to come to him.
- Yes, sir. Yes, sir.
The first few months, I'm just getting used to, like,
the, like, the culture, the people and, uh, the
basketball here.
And, uh, I just, I'm just very happy that I have my
whole family here.
I didn't really know a lot of things about college
recruitment cuz, uh, in the Philippines, I was still
at the 10th grade.
So, I wasn't really, like, focused on any college,
but when
I came here, you know, I, I just got a little shocked
that things are happening so fast and, uh, I just
have to be ready for it.
- I see Kai as somebody with a world
of potential, um,
and, and the sky's really the limit, but also, you
know, there's a short time to get there, and it
has to be deliberate and making
those goals achievable.
- The training here in the States is different
because they're really, like, focused, and my trainer
really dedicated themselves to help me get better
as a player.
- One thing that we wanted to really
work on, getting
him to be more NBA-ready, um, which means, you
know, can he handle the NBA, uh,
pace of the game,
physicality.
Um, can he use this link, uh, in a meaningful way?
Does he stretch the floor consistently?
Um, can he guard players?
Can he guard in the post?
Can he guard off switches?
- Coach Chuck Person, Coach Rob, Jeremiah.
They've been helping me a lot.
They're helping me prepare.
And, uh, I just, I just get my confidence from my
workouts, from my practices.
- I think for him to become,
become more physical,
a lot of it's gonna take some work at P3,
which he's working at every day.
They do a great job, um, kind of sports science
and, and strength and conditioning to develop him
off the court, which I think is really, really important.
- Here at P3, we assess our athletes so that
we know
what the needs are.
So with Kai, I think from, from this point on, it's
just a matter of continuing to develop his strength,
develop that power. He's gonna be playing and
matching up against guys who are bigger than him.
So making sure that he is able to match that
intensity on the court, but also making sure that
he stays healthy too to be able to
compete year-round.
- That was a moment in time for him at
Basketball Without Borders,
where all 30 NBA teams are there.
There's high-level kids that are his age that are
there, and he's able to see, you know, "I didn't
make the, the first team. I wasn't MVP. I wasn't on
the first-team all-camp.
Um, and so what are the things
I need to do to improve?"
And so now you're able to look at positive feedback
from GMs, scouts.
- Uh, it was great.
Uh, I had to—I had the opportunity to play against
the best players all over the world and, uh, to be
coached by great coaches.
- What are the gaps? What's gonna help
him get there?
And I think he took it to heart.
You know, I think he saw kind of where he was and
was able to size himself up a little bit.
And now he's able to take a step forward because
he's, he's grounded in reality.
He's not caught kind of in the hype world.
You know, potential is something people
talk about a lot, right?
Potential, potential, potential.
There's always a point, though, where you have to
start turning a corner, and potential has
to become reality.
And for him, he's starting to, to approach that phase.
And I think he understands that.
And so as long as he continues to
move forward and
progress, he's got every, every opportunity in the
world to be a good NBA player.
- My ultimate dream is to make it to the NBA.
And I also want to represent the Philippines on
international tournaments.
I just want to show that Philippines is part of the
basketball world.
I appreciate those people who follow me and my
journey, knowing that all my fellow Filipinos from
my country, you know, supporting me and, uh,
following me, and I just use it as a motivation,
inspiration, just to work even harder to
make them proud.